aujourd'hui on va par les télévisions on
va parler de ça regardez ça ce gros
carton la nouvelle télévision de lg
c'est la nano celles avec de
l'intelligence hi i think you 139 cm 55
pouces après monstre pour cible est en
projet charger votre télé si vous voulez
la renouveler chez vous intéresser au
monde merveilleux des téléviseurs des
téléviseurs atteignant des smart tv
on parle aujourd'hui de lg on parle
aujourd'hui nano c'est on parle
aujourd'hui d'écrans led vous allez voir
des trucs vachement talent qui arrive
[Musique]
regardez-moi ça grand écran clg
directement en cours et qui me l'a fait
envoyer merci à j ai regardé moi ce
grand écran vachement rial 55 pouces de
pur bonheur
alors 55 pouces si vous savez pas
l'aider donald qui parle de là et qui va
jusque là haut c'est du 139 cm c'est une
télé 4 k4 cas hdr hdr 10 c'est la capca
uhd à 3840 par 2160 pixels 4k uhd si
vous devez choisir une télé si vous
intéresser au fait de changer ou alors
d'acquérir une telle que vous donnez
jamais eu ça peut arriver parce que cet
écran led est intéressant qu'est ce que
peut vous apporter la nano sel est ce
que cet écran de lg intériste un écran
qu'arriver en 2019 à tout nouvel écran
est ce qu'il est bien oui non quoi
comment aujourd'hui on répond à ce
problème là on reparlera de lg avec un
écran oled d'ici quelques jours mais ça
c'est une autre histoire on en parlera
un peu plus tard l ge renouvelle sa
gamme en 2019 propose de nouveaux
produits vachement intéressant alors
vous avez le 55 pouces c'est la vraie de
65 pouces ces différentes tailles
c'est aux intérêts sera vite aller voir
le lien en bas dans la description et
surtout ce qui est intéressant c'est
technologie nano sel on va la faire très
très courtes ce que vous apporte une à
naucelle en fait c'est une amélioration
de l'image
vous avez une filtration qui ce fait et
grâce à des nanoparticules d'environ 1
nanomètre
votre lumière arrive à les filtrer et ça
vous restitue des couleurs beaucoup plus
vite
un contraste plus intenses grâce au full
led local dimming un noir beaucoup plus
profond c'est vraiment tout l'intérêt de
ce téléviseur en fait profiter d'une
image de meilleure qualité ça croyez moi
en termes de couleurs en termes de rendu
en cas de noirs en terme de contrats
sont d'une image qui est hyper
qualitatif et c'est vrai que pour ça en
tout cas c'est une nouvelle génération
de b19 vachement bien en plus derrière
vous avez un processeur c'est l'alpha
celle de deuxième génération qui
marchent merveilleusement bien qu'il va
venir travailler si vous voulez avec du
diplôme pour venir améliorer encore la
qualité de l'image et la qualité du son
là dessus vous avez deux visions vous
avez dolby et n'ose vous avez une
superbe qualité ça vous apporter la
réduction de bruit ça vous permet
d'avoir plus de détails sur votre image
plus de richesse au niveau du son en
gros grâce à ce processeur est grâce à l
intelligence artificielle
vous allez avoir une amélioration
significative de votre image et de vote
sont d'une manière globale
autre point qui est vachement
intéressant ça vous faire de
stehly en 4k parce que comme vous avez
un écran qui est en 4k uhd si vous
derrière vous avez une box avec par
exemple une définition qui est assez
moyenne
et vous n'avez pas une source en 4/4 et
bien soit en train de faire de l'ops
kelly c'est à dire que vous allez avoir
une image par exemple en full hd en
1080p ça vous le style et vous augmentez
la qualité pour avoir un équivalent en
4k pour pouvoir l'afficher justement sur
cet écran en cas de cas urgent d sans
aucune perte de qualité et bien au
contraire en améliorant la source de
base donc ça aussi plutôt bien
autre point intéressant avec ce
téléviseur quelque chose que vous
regarder de face bien évidemment c'est
là vous profitez de la meilleure
expérience mais point qui coule c'est
que lorsque vous mettez sur le côté vous
avez donc des visions qui est quand même
très large là je profite quand même
d'une image de qualité alors pas aussi
bones pétillement que si je me mets en
face mais langue des visions malgré tout
est quand même très bons donc le faites
vous m soit côté ça pose absolument
aucun problème
autre point et non des moindres le
design vous avez des bords qui sont
quand même hyper hyper hyper fin ça vous
permet effectivement lorsque vous
arrivez dans le mode galerie vous
l'affiché une belle image de palier
comme ça lors vous l'affiché une oeuvre
d'art est votre télé par exemple à les
poser paf à votre mur eh bien ça vous
permet de pouvoir afficher des tableaux
de venir à l'intégrer dans un intérieur
sans forcément avoir une chaîne de
télévision d'avoir un programme allumé
donc ça c'est aussi super intéressant
autre temps qui coule c'est le pied vous
avez un pied qui est bien dessiné en arc
de cercle comme ça qui est vraiment
hyper caritatif donc c'est un car il ya
un beau travail qui a été fait par alger
au niveau du design de ce produit vous
avez une superbe qualité d'image le son
est vraiment bien
immersif pour moi c'est une telle équipe
vraiment à terre et qui surtout est un
tarif qui est hyper avantageux puisque
en 55 pouces comme ça vouloir trouver un
petit peu moins de 1500 euros dont
serait qu'un excellent rapport
qualité-prix sur un grand écran 55
pouces a une fois de plus l g bravo à
toi qui vient avec ce téléviseur c'est
la navigation vous avez soit la
possibilité de venir naviguer avec les
boutons la pure sans droite gauche comme
vous le feriez avec une télécommande
classique soit venir l'utiliser avec ce
type water ça vous fait comme une petite
souris vous les déplacez vous déplacez
votre télécommande s'avoue déplace au
pointeur vous avez tout votre contenu
qui se situe en bas mais pouvoir
retrouver votre tableau de bord maison
votre recherche votre télé et ensuite
toutes vos applications
netflix rakuten tv ocs youtube une vidéo
je vous en passe et des meilleures
beaucoup d'applications pour venir
installer molotov téléporter les
compagnies écouter toute votre musique
vous allez pouvoir avoir spotify deezer
en application à installer toutes vos
photos des pouvoirs gier
et votre navigation internet votre
galerie si ça donc ça c'est vachement
cool et en plus tu peux venir
personnalisé moite et moi j'ai fait j'ai
mis ma chaîne youtube ici voyez je crie
j'arrive directement sur la chaîne
youtube avec mon contenu avec votre
télécommande la navigation hyper
intuitive vous naviguez voulait
descendre cette glisse et vous avez une
petite molette là vous venez la faire
glisser ça vous fait descendre et après
vous allez voir ce que vous voulez vous
avez tous vos contenus le fil de
promenades y est comme ça c'est cool
l'atypique manger du conduit qui
tournait en full hd grâce à lochte
kyling ça nous restitue sur cet écran
capté à eux hd c'est vraiment hyper
appréciable et source ap
assez cool de pouvoir cette expérience
de profiter de cette immersion et de
pouvoir voir ça sur cette grande télé
aux points qui coule vous avez un petit
micro là dessus pour l utiliser pour
parler à google assistant quel temps
fait-il à paris aujourd'hui vous en
raconte il fait une chaleur à la pas
fine il fait une chaleur absolu et c'est
vraiment ça qui est intéressant c'est
qu'en plus de télécommande vous pouvez
l'utiliser bien évidemment pour parler à
google assistant pour qu'ils vous disent
tous que vous non ça c'est bien mais en
plus ce qui intéresse en dessus vous
n'êtes pas dracon si netflix pas une
vidéo vous avez tous vos boutons savoir
c'est vraiment pratique
je la trouve assez complète facile à
utiliser elle est compatible google
assistant amazon alexa mais aussi apple
airplay de l'eau sc webos 4.5 en plus
pour l'installation on ne s'embête pas
vous avez une calibration automatique
enfin voilà elle est vraiment hyper
facile à installer à paramétrer point de
vue connectique est ce qu'il faut il ya
l'usb du hdmi de tous les côtés vous
avez plein de port hdmi
vous avez une sortie optique vous avez
une entrée l'année vous avez également
vos câbles d'antennes satelitte si en
plus vous êtes gamer pour venir jouer à
des jeux en 4k hdr intéressant ce qui
fait qu'on a un produit multimédia pour
l'intérieur de votre maison
lorsque vous voulez pas regarder la télé
peut l'utiliser en objets décoratifs
vous faites défiler vos photos pour
émettre des oeuvres d'art depuis votre
galerie beaucoup de possibilités vous
allez pouvoir utiliser bien évidemment
comme une télévision pour regarder des
programmes en direct notamment avec
motors tv vous allez pouvoir regarder de
la vod
en outre et avec un netflix avec plein
de vidéos avec tout ce que vous voulez y
ait beaucoup de services compatibles
vous allez pouvoir jouer à des jeux tout
ça en 4k uhd hdr avec un excellent saut
avec une excellente qualité au niveau de
l'affichage avec un bon angle de vision
je trouve que lg a vraiment fait un bon
travail est suave me permettre ce que
vous en pensez en bas en commentaire
comment vous la trouvez cette télé à
naucelle
l'aide est ce qu'elle est intéressante
oui non quoi comment vous marquez tout
ça on reste connectés par l'enfant s'il
vous intéresse bien évidemment vous avez
un lien en bas dans la description et
quant à moi je donne rendez vous dès
demain est très prochainement pour
parler encore de lg et télé à bientôt
ciao